and I was really [ __ ] full of myself
and and I got a script called Fright
Night
right an offer to do this movie and and
I said to myself as I picked up and
looked at the the title of it uh on the
cover page oh I I can't do a movie
called fright night I'm a terribly
important actor right and so and so uh
but but you know these people they they
offered me the role and you offer you
you owe them the courtesy of reading it
and I started reading it and within like
five minutes I was completely sucked in
and by the time I finished the script I
said I have to do this I got to meet
these people and it it it taught me a
lesson uh which is you know the old
bromide don't love judge a book by its
cover don't let judge a screenplay by
its title right uh and and also
um art comes in many forms
and I've always considered that when I
first started I first started in the
theater yes and I've continued to do
theater throughout my career and that
keeps you grounded
uh because you are in a a medium that
forces you to collaborate with people in
a totally different way than it does in
the movies than television but uh the
Fright Night people all we're all still
friends you know I I'm in touch with
them you know maybe a couple of times a
month John Stark and Tom Holland and and
Amanda Burse and Bill Ragsdale uh but
you know whatever we do a convention
where the movie is featured we get
together and we sit and we talk and we
eat and we laugh
a lot yeah laugh a lot did you have any
idea I mean I know you liked the script
and it drew you to you know
you know take the part uh in Fright
Night as Jerry Dandridge but did you did
you while you were filming did you say
there's something special here there's
something different here I thought so
absolutely
script was great and also Tom knew
exactly how he wanted to shoot the movie
he described it to me when we first met
he he went through it's literally scene
by saying shot by shot he described the
whole of Tom Holland I love that man I
played yeah he's into his house he's a
he's a he's an extraordinary guy well he
obviously loved you because he brought
you in the child's play as well yeah
yeah he fought Tom fought for me on that
movie really the studio yeah the studio
didn't want me and and the producers and
Tom basically said I if I'm going to do
this movie and I'm going to do it with
him
foreign